كما ذكر صاحب السمو الملكي
للرئيس أن مثل هذه الأخطاء تحدث
في دول أخرى ورأينا خطأ
مثل هذا ارتكبته الولايات
المتحدة في أبو رب وأن الولايات
المتحدة اتخذت خطوات للتعامل مع
أولئك الذين ثبتت إدانتهم و
لضمان وضع آليات
لمنع حدوث ذلك مرة أخرى
أوضح للرئيس أن
مملكة الصهاجة اتخذت تدابير
لضمان عدم حدوث مثل هذا الوضع
مرة أخرى ، كما ذكر صاحب السمو الملكي
أن عددًا من الدول في
عدد  من البلدان في جميع أنحاء العالم
لديك حالات
قتل فيها صحفيون ويجب على تلك الدول
اتخاذ خطوات من أجل تقديم
المسؤولين إلى العدالة والتأكد
من عدم حدوث ذلك مرة أخرى ، كما
أثار قضية
الصحفي الفلسطيني الأمريكي  التي
قتلها جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
والحاجة إلى ضمان
التعامل مع هذه القضية بشكل صحيح حتى تصبح هذه القضايا
مؤسفة  تحدث الأخطاء في جميع
أنحاء العالم ، والمهم
هو التعامل معها بشكل فعال
وحاسم